[Music]
on this Friday night closed canceled and
confined the Prime Minister's new
reality I am in isolation as are my my
children and my wife is in quarantine
his promise we will help Canadians
finish as the travel plans of thousands
of Canadians go up in the air postpone
or cancel all non-essential travel
outside of Canada and in the u.s. I am
officially declaring a national
emergency two very big words
[Music]
[Music]
upon my doctor's recommendation I will
remain in self isolation for 14 days I
want to be clear I have no symptoms and
I'm feeling good and technology allows
me to work from home of course it's an
inconvenience and somewhat frustrating
we are all social beings after all but
we have to do this because we have to
protect our neighbors and our friends
especially are more vulnerable seniors
and people with pre-existing conditions
mady's Canada's Prime Minister confined
to his own home
by the coronavirus these are
extraordinary times good evening and
thanks for joining us the Prime Minister
is not sick does not have kovat 19:00
but his wife Sophie Gregoire Trudeau
does and so he's working from home this
pandemic is having a profound impact on
all of us and events are moving fast
here's where we're at right now
Canadians are advised to avoid all
non-essential travel outside the country
Parliament has suspended sitting for at
least five weeks the Bank of Canada cut
interest rates today 2.75% National
museums across the country are closing
Europe has been declared the epicentre
of the pandemic and the American
president has declared a national
emergency the number of cases in Canada
keeps rising there are now almost 200
confirmed cases of Kove in 1917 PSA's
now have cases Ontario is reporting the
biggest jump in new cases 19 in the past
24 hours we have lots of ground to cover
tonight let's start with David akin in
Ottawa and the message from the Prime
Minister David that's right Donna it was
almost as if to underline the fact that
being at home and self-isolation does
not mean being an active Justin Trudeau
his cabinet the Bank of Canada made a
blizzard of announcements Friday I know
that you're worried you're worried about
your health about your family's health
about your job your savings about paying
rent
about the kids not being in school I
know that you're concerned about
uncertainty in the global economy so the
government is tackling all those
concerns first Trudeau added his weight
to what other provinces have said and
what Canada's top doctor said do not
travel outside Canada
there were also new travel protocols
that will affect all overseas flights to
Canada and all cruise ships that want to
dock in Canada every order of government
is working to stop the spread of the
virus businesses and citizens are taking
precautions we have outstanding public
health authorities who are doing an
outstanding job we will get through this
then the Bank of Canada jumped in with
an emergency interest rate cut of 50
basis points bringing the overnight rate
down to 0.75 percent that followed a 50
basis point rate cut just two weeks ago
Finance Minister Bill Morneau pumped 10
billion dollars into new lending
programs for business and tweaked the
rules that banks have to abide by that
frees up another three hundred billion
dollars in lending capacity as your
Minister of Finance we are going to do
whatever it takes to protect Canadians
and keep our economy strong
in the meantime Trudeau and his cabinet
are preparing a financial stimulus
package that could be worth between 20
and 40 billion dollars true to discuss
the plan with the Premier's on a
conference call on Friday afternoon and
expects to announce details next week no
one should have to worry about paying
rent buying groceries or additional
childcare because of covet 19 we will
help Canadians financially and finally
Donna in a rare show of unity all
political parties agreed to suspend
Parliament temporarily and peace and
sanity senators pardon me
will not be back here in the capital
until April the 20th all right David our
Trudeau and his kids sharing the house
with Sophie or is she shut herself away
in a separate part of the house in order
to reduce passing the virus on to him
and is he being tested we talked to
Trudeau's aides about Sophie status and
they were reluctant to tell us much
about it
Trudeau himself did say she's in
quarantine while he and the kids are in
isolation the difference there
apparently the Prime Minister and his
kids are interacting but sophie is not
while she's in quarantine now as for
Trudeau being tested in terms of advice
I've gotten from medical professionals
it was explained explained to me that as
long as I do not show any symptoms at
all there is no value in having me
tested and experts say that actually
saves scarce health resources no need to
take the test until you're symptomatic
and he is in self-isolation in the
meantime David akin in Ottawa thanks the
prime minister's wife was in London last
week so if he spoke at an event for
International Women's Day at Canada
House and today Canada's High
Commissioner to the UK Janis Charette
said she is also self isolating at home
as a precaution and everyone else who
attended the event at Canada House is
being contacted this pandemic is
altering all of our lives in ways we
never imagined a few weeks ago that
includes the tens of thousands of
families who had trips planned for March
break now we're told all travel outside
Canada is a risk and should be avoided
even the Canadian military has banned
all foreign travel an ordered
non-essential personnel to stay home
Jeff simple looks at what Canadians need
to know about travel during this
pandemic Jeff well Donna Pearson
International is Canada's busiest
airport and this is typically its second
busiest day of the year ahead of March
Break this time last year saw more than
140,000 passengers pass through here but
take a look the picture today is much
different
no lineups a check-in or security for
passengers at Pierson the airport hired
extra staff for the spring break rush
but in hindsight probably didn't need to
given the situation with regard to Cove
in nineteen we are expecting and seeing
an impact
Susan Rasmussen family had tickets to
fly to the southern US but decided to
stay put we didn't want to catch the
virus plus we did not want to bring it
back with us this Edmonton couple
learned about the government's travel
advisory from Global News at the airport
and promptly cancelled their trip things
are changing so quickly right now but
others like this family heading to Cuba
are packing supplies and taking their
chances but it is scary we were much
enthusiastic and much excited and then
now we're traveling with a little bit of
scare but those who do decide to travel
abroad may find themselves with an
uncomfortable homecoming cruise ships
with more than 500 passengers will no
longer be allowed to dock in Canada the
federal government is asking anyone who
travels abroad to report symptoms such
as a cough or fever and those who return
from Italy Iran or who Bay China are
being told to self isolate for 14 days
what we have to remember is that viruses
don't know borders some passengers told
global news that their employers had
warned them if they travel they won't be
paid for two weeks probably within an
employer's right to say I want to take a
precaution and not allow these people to
or and and not have these people work
for a period of time but if you make it
an unpaid layoff that's going to be a
problem and passengers arriving here to
Canada can also expect more disruption
in the weeks ahead the government plans
to restrict the number of airports in
Canada that can receive international
passengers and introduce new screening
measures for those arriving from abroad
Donna Jeff simple in Toronto thanks now
to the United States President Trump has
declared a national emergency that
offered individual states billions of
dollars in support as he spoke
stock markets began to surge after days
of sharp declines and there's a report a
second person who was at mar-a-lago with
President Trump last weekend has now
tested positive for the corona by
Abigale Beeman reports on how life is
changing in the US the action I am
taking will open up access to up to
fifty billion dollars President Donald
Trump declaring a national emergency in
an effort to contain the virus but as he
promised more tests he downplayed the
gravity of the need five million within
a month I doubt we'll need anywhere near
that we don't want people to take a test
if if we feel that they shouldn't be
doing it
Trump shook hands and touched people at
the announcement he promised more
drive-through testing sites today New
York State opened its first in New
Rochelle the hard-hit area under
containment there are six lanes that are
operating you drive in in your car and
the medical staff comes to you does the
test takes the swabs testing is still
not where it should be in the u.s.
admits one of the country's top doctors
what we really need is to get the test
available in venues that people could
easily access it is very likely we will
have that within the next week or so
long lines of this New York grocery
store with empty shelves a regular site
one example of how daily life in America
is changing we're trying to stay calm
several states are shutting down all
schools I don't have the option just
time-lock so here they are meanwhile
lawmakers have been debating a bill to
provide aid including expanding paid
sick days the three most important parts
of this bill are testing testing testing
this legislation facilitates free
coronavirus testing for everyone who
needs a test but its future remains
uncertain with the president saying what
the House Democrats proposed wasn't
enough
Abigail Beeman Global News Washington
experts are looking at Europe to predict
what's coming here in a matter of weeks
and it's not good
today the w-h-o declared Europe is now
the epicentre of this pandemic Italy
which had its first outbreak on February
23rd is now overwhelmed with more than
15,000 cases and over 1000 people have
died that all happened in just 20 days
outbreaks in Spain Germany and France
are also growing exponentially just one
week ago those countries were each
reporting a few hundred cases now there
are more than 4300 in Spain 3100 cases
in Germany and more than 2,800 in France
doctors in Ireland are warning that
country is 14 days behind Italy the
worry is that if the spread isn't slowed
down through things like shutting down
travel and public events health care
systems across Europe will be
overwhelmed crystal commencing reports a
state of emergency takes effect Saturday
in Spain after a surge of infections in
Europe it is the second to Italy for
cope at 19 cases Spanish officials warn
the infection rate could more than
double to 10,000 by next week the Czech
Republic also declaring a state of
emergency it is closing its borders to
travelers crossing from Germany and
Austria Austria is following Italy
closing all shops except grocery stores
pharmacies and banks beginning Monday
Germany meanwhile is reassuring people
with an economic pledge a half a
trillion euros to support Europe's
largest economy in France public
gatherings are limited to 100 people the
Louvre Eiffel Tower and several other
historic attractions are
closed mcqueen cancelled two upcoming
public appearances Buckingham Palace
says other events will be reviewed on an
ongoing basis crystal the Manson Global
News London
empty shells overflowing shopping carts
coming up the pointless panic buying
going on across Canada
you may have witnessed scenes like this
yourself
there was advice from public health
officials to slowly stockpile some
essentials in case you need to self
isolate some are taking that way too far
there's been panic buying in some cases
people are buying vast amounts and
selling it at a profit
others are hoarding just in case this is
crazy this is the craziest I've seen yes
I was worried I wouldn't find supplies
would you buy toilet paper hand
sanitizer and almond flour well here's
the thing the retail Council of Canada
which represents all major grocery
chains in Canada is urging consumers not
to panic buy because Canada has one of
the best supply chains in the world what
are you gonna do with all that toilet
paper anyway as restrictions are put in
place to slow the spread of kovat 19
there is the question about whether or
not to close schools in this country
Italy Spain even France of shut schools
entirely for at least two weeks some
provinces in Canada have followed suit
and universities are moving courses
online as Ross Lord reports the right
approach is a lesson in itself shutting
down schools is an obvious option for
limiting the spread of covered 19 first
Ontario decided to keep publicly funded
schools closed for an extra two weeks
after March Break when Ontario families
to know we are unwavering in our focus
in keeping students and staff safe
followed by neighboring Quebec which has
already had March break the felony to
please Zika seizure University e self is
the gala all schools and daycares closed
for two weeks
Manitoba then announced it was following
suit other provinces are taking a softer
approach urging anyone who travels
outside Canada to stay at home for 14
days after they return including
students and their families but stopping
short of keeping everyone away from
schools the level of the disease is
differs between province and province
and the strength of of your public
health measures therefore needs to be
will be differ we need to understand
or about the role of young people in
transmission of this disease and we know
that sometimes that the impacts of
closing schools particularly abruptly
can cause a lot of societal disruption
and economic impact medical experts say
keeping the doors closed throughout
Canada is inevitable I think it's
definitely the next thing to happen in
the provinces that have not done it
depending on what happened over the next
few days of the outbreak for parents
there's no perfect solution so it's
better to be closed but this is my
opinion because I'm not working in
provinces forcing closures working
parents wonder how they'll supervise
their children I don't know what we're
gonna do but we'll have to figure it out
more universities by the day are closing
or shifting courses to online only
but kovat 19 is revealing how much
everyone wants to do the right thing and
how hard it is to figure out what that
is
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
overcrowded and remote communities ahead
the risks some indigenous Canadians face
to many indigenous communities in Canada
have poor housing and limited access to
medical services and that puts them at
higher risk as this virus spreads
Heather Urich's West explains what's
being done to prepare remote communities
for what's coming
members of southern Alberta's Blackfoot
Confederacy are planning their next
steps looking at how the elected leaders
of the pukani Siksika and kaya First
Nation can help their people prepare for
Kovach 19 we don't want our youth you
know infected we don't want our elders
infected you know we're looking at
everybody in the community on the
Siksika nation east of Calgary visits to
the elders Lodge have been restricted
several large events have been cancelled
but the housing on this reserve is a
major concern as well should somebody
possibly get diagnosed or you know the
tests come out positive and they are in
a hole and overcrowd at home of let's
say 10 12 people and the treatment is to
isolate yourself we have 54 percent
overcrowding in relation to housing and
with the increased conversation about
self isolation if there are kovat 19
outbreaks in some communities that just
won't be an option for for many inuit in
many remote indigenous communities
accessing local health services is not
an option either if there is a situation
that does come into the media community
we don't have no nursing centers we have
no health centers and we have no health
staff what happens when it hits our
villages the federal government says
it's working on solutions they've
promised financial support and they're
working to procure specialized isolation
tents for screening and testing for
communities without adequate
infrastructure temporary shelters are
also being considered help indigenous
leaders say will be critical as kovat 19
spreads Heather Urich's West Global News
Calgary next where to find optimism
during this pandemic
you are watching global national we left
the good news for last and yes there is
some good news about this virus the vast
majority of people who get Kovac 19 have
mild symptoms and recover from it in
fact roughly half of the 137 thousand
people who have caught this virus
worldwide that includes tens of
thousands of people in China where it
started have recovered Eric Sorensen
shares some optimistic news during a
dark time it is a look of modern
desolation empty arenas political
chambers airports images of society and
retreat an empty feeling has swept the
world more quickly than kovat 19 the
stock market's the instant pulse of the
economy from big gains to bigger losses
symbolizes the swings between hope and
despair it's easy to find reason for
pessimism 3,000 deaths in China alone
from an especially efficient virus and
Italy demonstrates that a modern nation
with impressive health care could not
keep up and the numbers are climbing
daily our closest neighbor may well have
responded way later than it should have
anybody that wants a test and in this
country line ups for basic food is a
shocking sight but consider reasons for
optimism even at a time like this in
China the first wave of this pandemic
appears to be receding Chinese
mobilisation to build hospitals was
remarkable South Korea where cases
spiked sharply aggressive measures like
10,000 tests per day has limited the
number of deaths in Africa an
impoverished continent recently saw its
first cases but a warmer climate may be
more resistant to this virus and
Africans have exceptional experience
dealing with deadly diseases children
appear to have greater immunity that is
wonderful news and for the elderly and
vulnerable this nation sense of calm and
concern has been a hallmark of Canada's
response and while social distancing
will buy as time
Toronto's Sunnybrook Research Institute
and two universities have isolated the
kovat 19 virus the first step to war
it's better treatment and a vaccine so
in the meantime there is human spirit in
hard-hit Italy serving coffee with
imagination and on a deserted street a
serenade from one apartment to the
neighbors there is reason to be
pessimistic and optimistic but we can
bridge the two by being realistic
righto love that and mady's global
national for this friday i'm dona
freezin tonight's your Canada is the CN
tower that defines Toronto skyline the
landmark shut its doors to the public
until next month but will still be lit
up every night and will be here each
night as well Robin Gill is at the
anchor desk this weekend and I'll see
you again soon thanks for watching and
have a lovely weekend bye-bye
[Music]
you